>> ♪ ♪
THIS IS THE INGRAHAM ANGLE ON
WASHINGTON THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US THIS SATURDAY NIGHT.
SHADOW SHATTERED MY EXCESSIVE
FOCUS ON TONIGHT ANGLE.
THE BLIZZARD OF DATA IS
UNDENIABLE.
IF COVID LOCKDOWN.
THE GENDER FLUIDITY OF RADICALS,
THE POP PUSHERS HAVE A DOING A
NUMBER ON YOUNG AMERICANS AND
ATTENDING EMMETT TILL IN
GENERATION OF DAZED AND
CONFUSED.
AND OF COURSE KIDS WHO ARE
LOOKING FOR LOVE'S AND ALL WRONG
PLACES.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, THE 70
ROCKERS IN THE WHO?
IS BECOME CLEAR THAT THE KIDS
ARE NOT ALL RIGHT.
>> I ALWAYS HAD REALLY GOOD
GRADES, AND THEN, AS SOON AS THE
PANDEMIC IT, I FAIL THE CLASS.
WHEN I WAS VIRTUAL.
I HAD NO MOTIVATION TO DO
ANYTHING.
I WOULD JUST, SIT AND BE IN MY
ROOM AND NEVER LEAVE.
AND IT WAS AN OBVIOUS SIGN OF
DEPRESSION.
>> MY MENTAL HEALTH THAT
REALLY BAD, ESPECIALLY MY EATING
DISORDER.
I WAS BASICALLY HOME ALONE ALL
DAY.
>> SADLY THIS IS A STORY OF A
GROWING TREND.
THEY ARE IN THE MIDST OF A
FULL-BLOWN MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS
REPORTING THAT THE CDC FOUND
NEARLY 45% OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WERE PERSISTENTLY SAD,
OR HOPELESS IN 2021.
IN ALMOST ONE IN FIVE SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERED SUICIDE, AND 9% IN
THIS SATURDAY TRY TO TAKE THEIR
LIVES DURING THE PREVIOUS 12
MONTHS.
IT TURNS OUT LOCKING KIDS DOWN,
ROBBING THEM OF SOCIALIZATION,
ROBBING THEM OF SORTS, AND KIM
MILESTONES, AND THEY CONFUSING
THEM WITH GENDER FLUIDITY
PROPAGANDA, DOES THAT MAKE THEM
AND WELL-ADJUSTED.
WHAT IF THE KIDS TO GO TO BE
KIDS ANYMORE?
EVERYWHERE YOU TURN, THIS MENTAL
HEALTH EPIDEMIC IS EXPLODING.
LIKE IN NORTH CAROLINA, WHERE
THEY ARE IN DIRE NEED OF MORE
PSYCH BEDS TO ADDRESS THE
WORSENING CRISIS AS THEY ARE.
AND THEN ONE IS IN WISCONSIN,
THEIR YOUTH RISK BEHAVIOR SURVEY
RAISES MORE RED FLAGS.
18% OF TEENS, SAY THAT THEY
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED SUICIDE IN
THE PAST YEAR.
THE HIGHEST LEVEL SINCE 2,003.
IN THAT PERCENTAGE JUMPS TO
NEARLY HALF, FOR THOSE WHO ARE
LGBT, AND BISEXUAL STUDENTS.
AND FEMALE STUDENTS WITH MORE
THAN TWO TIMES AS LIKELY TO
THINK ABOUT SUICIDE THAN MALES.
THIS IS COMPLETELY OUTRAGEOUS
AND HEARTBREAKING.
SOMEBODY -- AND SOMETHING IS
VERY WRONG WITH WHAT WE ARE
DOING TO OUR CHILDREN.
WHY DID WE HAVE SUCH HIGH
SUICIDE RATES IN THE 80s?
WHAT ABOUT THE 60s OR THE
50s?
AND WE CANNOT FORGET THE SCOURGE
OF LEGALIZED MARIJUANA, HOW THAT
HAS AFFECTED OUR YOUNG KIDS
MENTAL HEALTH.
LEVERAGING MEDIA, AND THE
PRO-POP POLITICIANS, AND THEY
ARE LURED BY BIG DOLLARS A
CAMPAIGN CONTENT DONATION.
THEY ACTIVELY PROMOTE THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
THE HIGH THC CONTENT DRUG IS
MARKETED AS KIND OF A MAGIC
ELIXIR FOR ALL THAT AILS YOU.
AND IT IS PACKAGED IN EVERYTHING
FROM ENTICING EDIBLES, TO SALTY
SNACKS.
WELL ACTUALLY WITHOUT THE ADULTS
DOING, OPENLY AND PROUDLY, THE
KIDS SAFE THINK IT'S FINE TOO.
ADOLESCENT CANNABIS ABUSE, HAS
INCREASED BY A WHOPPING 245% IN
THE UNITED STATES SINCE 2,000.
AND IT IS REALLY TAKING OFF JUST
IN THE PAST TWO YEARS.
BETA WEIGHT AND ITS ACOLYTES TO
PRATTLE ON ABOUT HOW IT IS
BETTER FOR KIDS AND ALCOHOL.
AND IT IS NOT AS ADDICTING, BUT
THE STORIES FROM PARENTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY TELL A VERY
DIFFERENT TALE.
>> I HAVE A SON, WHO STARTED
SMOKING MARIJUANA IN THE
EIGHTH GRADE, AND THEN SMOKES
MARIJUANA CONSISTENTLY AND
PERSISTENTLY.
AND HE DID THIS ALL THROUGH
HIGH SCHOOL, AND THEN AT AGE 18
HE HAD HIS FIRST PSYCHOTIC
BREAK.
TODAY HE HAS SCHIZOPHRENIC
DISORDER WITH COOCCURRING
SUBSTANCE ISSUES AND HE WILL
NEVER RECOVER.
>> HE VERY QUICKLY BECAME
ADDICTED, FIVE YEARS LATER, HE
DIED BY SUICIDE SAYING, THAT THE
MOP WAS AFTER HIM.
HE BECAME COMPLETELY DELUSIONAL.
>> YET THE LEFTIST BURROWED
INTO OUR SCHOOLS, THEY DO NOT
SEE THE CARE ABOUT ANY OF THIS.
AND YOU DO NOT SEE THE
PERMISSIVENESS TO ITS DRUGS IS
ANY REAL CULPRIT.
TAKE WISCONSIN STATE
SUPERINTENDENT GUILT UNDER ME.
>> BUILDING A LOCAL GIVING AND
SAFETY COMMUNITY ONE THAT
FOSTERS A SENSE OF COMMUNITY AND
LAUNDRY WITH EVERY CHILD FEEL
SAFE WORKERS MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT WITH MANDEL'S IS A
COMMUNITY'S RHETORIC TO TRY AND
PASS POLICIES THAT FUNDAMENTALLY
UNWELCOME WAY UNSAFE.
SUCH A RHETORIC AND POLICIES ARE
HARMFUL AND DANGEROUS TO
STUDENTS EMOTIONAL SAFETY.
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH.
>> EVEN A SANDWICH HE SAYING
THERE?
IF THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH KIDS
MENTAL HEALTH, THE DEPRAVED
CULTURE, THE LOCKDOWN THEY ARE
NOT TO BLAME.
IT IS THE PARENTS WHO ARE
SPEAKING UP AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS, THEY ARE THE PROBLEM.
>> CONFIRMING IDENTITIES AND
LANGUAGE HIM FOR -- THEY CREEP
ALONG THE WAY.
AFFIRMING IDENTITIES AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION.
IT IS PROVEN SELF-CARE.
IT IS STRONG MENTAL HEALTH
PRACTICE.
PRONOUNS, SAVE, LIES.
SO LET ME SAY THIS.
>> THERE IS ACTUALLY APPLAUSE
FOR THAT PRONOUN SAVE LIVES.
THAT WOMAN IS A SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE OF WISCONSIN.
NO WONDER THE KIDS ARE SO
DEPRESSED.
MAYBE DR. UNDERLAY, AND THE
EDGER CUTS LIKE HER SHOULD GET
THEIR HEADS OUT OF THE ABRAM CAN
BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON FIRST
PRINCIPLES.
PARENTS OF CHILDREN STRUGGLING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH TODAY ARE IN
SUCH A BIND, THAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO PUT THE KIDS INTO
SPECIAL EDUCATION JUST TO GET
THEM MORE RESOURCES FOR THEIR
BETTERMENT.
DURING COVID, HEIDI WHITMAN SAW
HER DAUGHTER AT A MIDDLE OR
SPIRAL.
I THINK BECAUSE SHE WENT TO THE
PANDEMIC ADDEND AND EXPERIENCE A
MORE NORMAL JUNIOR HIGH, THE
NUMBER OF MIDDLE SCHOOL
EXPERIENCE, SHE DEVELOPED THE
EXCITING AND THE DEEP DEPRESSION
AS SHE DID NOT LINE.
SHE DIDN'T LEARN TO BE A SOCIAL
KID AND EVERYTHING GOT TURNED ON
ITS HEAD.
ULTIMATELY OF COURSE HER
DAUGHTER WAS HOSPITALIZED IN A
PSYCH WARD, AND FAILED PRETTY
MUCH EVERYTHING AT SCHOOL WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH DEPRESSION, AND
ADHD.
AND SHE IS NOW A SPECIAL ED.
OUR CHILDREN ARE CRYING OUT FOR
HELP.
AND NOBODY IS ANSWERING.
IN OUR SCHOOLS ARE FAILING THEM,
OUR MEDICAL ESTABLISHMENT IS
FAILING THEM, OUR GOVERNMENT IS
FAILING THEM, AND NOW THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO SCREWED UP OUR KIDS
ARE TRYING TO BLAME SHIFT THE
PARENTS.
THEY ARE FINALLY STANDING UP TO
THESE PEOPLE THESE PAYMENTS.
NICE TRY.
BUT IS NOT IN A WORK.
BECAUSE ONE BY ONE, WERE GOING
TO EXPOSE THE TRUE FRAUDS HERE.
THE PEOPLE, THE ACTIVIST GROUPS
WHO ARE DESTROYING OUR CHILDREN
BOTH EMOTIONALLY, AND
PHYSICALLY.
IT IS TIME TO GET BACK TO THE
BASICS, HIGH STANDARDS IN THE
ACADEMY.
COACADEMICS, ATHLETICS, SCHOOL
SPIRIT, CLEARER THINKING, AND
CIVIC VIRTUE.
GOD MAY HAVE BEEN KICKED OUT OF